Справа активістки та волонтерки Катерини Гандзюк,
яку 31 липня облили сірчаною кислотою в Херсоні,
під контролем керівництва Нацполіції та Генпрокурора України.
Вони обіцяють шв идке та ефективне розслідування.
DW згадала інші резонансні напади на активістів за останній рік.
Розслідування щодо них, попри великий розголос і обіцянки політиків,
поки ні до чого не призвели.
У перший день 2018 року на Київщині знайшли тіло правозахисниці Ірини Ноздровської,
яка померла від багатьох колото-різаних ран.
У скоєному зізнався Юрій Россошанський,
син якого збив сестру Ноздровської та засудження якого довго добивалася правозахисниця.
Через майже 8 місяців наприкінці серпня відбулося підготовче засідання в Ірпінському суді.
Щоправда, деякі активісти досі сумніваються, що покарають справді винного.
Рік тому в Одесі побили засновницю руху "Зелений лист", антикорупціонерку Світлану Подпалу.
Керівництво Нацполіції також взяло слідство під особистий контроль.
Напад кваліфікують як побутовий, суд розпочався ще минулого року,
але далі кількох попередніх слухань справа не просунулась.
А ось так в лютому виглядав офіс рівненського бюро
Агенції журналістських розслідувань "Четверта влада",
яка пише про бурштинові війни, незаконні забудови та корупцію в освіті.
В липні поліція затримала двох виконавців.
До суду справа ще не дійшла.
Організатор нападу, місцевий кримінальний авторитет, втік за кордон.
Великий розголос викликав напад 24 травня на Сергія Стерненка,
вже третій від лютого цього року.
Активний майданівець, екс-керівник одеського "Правого сектору" опинився в лікарні,
один з нападників загинув, інший - в статусі свідка під державною охороною.
Через конфлікт активіста з одеською поліцією
справу передали в Київ, у Головне слідче управління Нацполіції.
Результатів досі немає.
Ще один кричущий напад стався на суддю у Полтаві.
Минулого листопада невідомі побили суддю Ларису Гольник,
яка відмовилася закрити кримінальне провадження
за звинуваченням у корупції мера міста Олександра Мамая
записала на відео спробу підкупити її та передала зйомку поліції.
Попри відео з двадцяти камер спостереження,
ані виконавців, ані замовників досі буцімто не знайшли.